Hi there. Welcome to my session today.
This session is titled Cluster API as Code.
And I want to use the time that
I have today to introduce you to the
Kubernetes cluster API, as well as some higher
level user friendly obstructions
and libraries that I've been working on in
my spare time.
Now a little bit about me. My name
is David McKay. I am from Glasgow in
Scotland
and I am a developer advocate. I work
for a company called Equinix Metal. You may
be familiar with them. They were formerly called
Packet and they had a bare metal cloud
provider.
I'm very fortunate that they sponsor most of
my time to produce educational materials to help
people learn how to consume the vast cloud
native landscape. So please check out my channel.
The link is in the bottom right corner.
I'm also an active Kubernetes contributor and I,
you know, take full responsibility for Dan pop
eating a pineapple pizza on my stream a
few weeks ago.
Now, what is the cluster API? It is
a Kubernetes
SIG sub project
that aims to commoditize
the way that we provision our Kubernetes cluster.
It has a declarative API,
much like everything else in Kubernetes
and in which we write YAML to apply
to our cluster.
And then the controllers within the cluster do
the thing that we want them to do.
And this case, cluster API is providing this
declarative API and that we can define a
Kubernetes cluster and the YAML,
apply that to a Kubernetes cluster
and it creates a Kubernetes cluster.
The responsibilities of the cluster API are to
create and provision these clusters,
but then a little bit more. The cluster
API
can upgrade
your cluster.
It also has some special provisions and it
tries to handle any operations if things go
wrong or we lose machines within our cluster
nodes within our clusters.
And it also has some limited support
for a get ops style deployment of applications
to the clusters.
It is currently in B1 alpha three, so
it's still early days in the Cluster API
project, but it has a lot of support
from all the major cloud providers
and a very active community.
And it's a very collaborative project.
It has support from my company Equinix Metal,
but also from AWS, from Google, from digital
ocean and all these other major players.
So the cluster API is becoming a very,
very great option
as being the primary tooling for one to
use to create new Kubernetes clusters. This
is the logo. And if you're not familiar,
I love the logo. I just thought I'd
bring it in on the slides, but it's
turtle stacking, right? Kubernetes all the way down.
You need Kubernetes to get Kubernetes.
And
I love the logo.
Now there's a little, a little bit of
a caputary, but one has to become accustomed
to to work with a cluster API.
Now the first one is we talk about
management clusters and workload clusters.
The management cluster tends to be or is
going to be the cluster that is running
the cluster API controllers.
This is the first cluster, the origin cluster.
This is the one that controls and creates
all other clusters.
And
then we have the workload clusters, which are
the clusters that we applied to the management
cluster that we want to be created.
Now it's very common at least and getting
started guides and other tutorials that are available
online
to use Docker for Mac or Kind or
MiniKube Azure management cluster.
And that is perfectly okay in some situations.
Of course, if you want the longer term
reconciliation options that Cluster API provides, you're gonna
wanna use a slightly longer term cluster.
And cluster API has a mechanism for that
too. You can use cluster API, you can
choose these ephemeral clusters like Kine Mini Kube
and Docker for Mac to create a Kubernetes
cluster and then move
that controller loop to your first production cluster,
Very viable option.
We also have infrastructure providers. Now Cluster API
can't do much on its own. You have
to install a provider. The providers being AWS,
Digital Ocean, GCP or Equinix metal.
Once you have one of those providers enabled
one or more of those providers enabled on
your management cluster, you can then create new
clusters on all of those infrastructures.
So that's the primary vocabulary and most of
what you need to get started.
Then when we beyond and we're talking about
creating clusters,
we need to talk about the primitives involves
for that too. Now this
requires you to write YAML that first defines
a machine deployment.
The machine deployment is like a node group
or a node pool if you're familiar with
other methods of spinning up clusters
that is responsible for managing a machine set
and then we have a machine set which
is responsible for managing the individual machines.
We also have the ability to apply machine
health checks to this that tells when the
machine is healthy or not healthy to allow
the controllers to then take away those broken
machines and bring in and replace them with
new machines.
Of course this should feel really really familiar.
If you have been working with Kubernetes for
any length of time, you're gonna be familiar
with the hierarchy
of I have a deployment
which manages replica sets, which manages pods and
we have probes.
Very similar when you group this together, it's
just that we're no longer talking about applications
or services or pods, we're talking about Kubernetes
clusters.
So
it should feel familiar
and hopefully that's all you need to understand
to really start kicking the tires with the
cluster API.
Now the best way to kind of show
you the Cluster API would just be to
give you a demo
and instead of actually doing these commands locally
and waiting for a cluster to spin up,
I'm just gonna run through the quick start
guide to highlight some of the more important
components and process steps that you need to
go through.
And then there'll be a slight little more
elaborate demo at the end with the abstraction
that I wanna provide on top.
So here we are.
This is the cluster API
quick start on the cluster API book. The
URL is in the corner. You can search
Google for cluster API quick start. It'll take
you right to it. Now of course cluster
API does require a Kubernetes cluster upfront. Today
I will be using Docker for Mac but
you can use many cube, you can use
kind, you can use any managed cluster from
any cloud provider that you want.
Once we have that cluster in place, we
just need to make sure our cube config
is working and that just means I can
run cube control,
get nodes, get pods, etcetera and it's gonna
work.
Now because there is a significant amount of
Yamo required to create a Kubernetes cluster,
you will need the cluster CTL command to
first install the provider and then generate the
manifest that we wanna apply to create the
workload cluster.
You can just download this with the curl
command from the documentation, stick it down to
your path and run it
much like any other binary on your machine.
Now to initialize the management cluster, there are
instructions for all of the providers that are
already supported. You can use AWS, Azure, Docker,
etcetera, etcetera, etcetera, etcetera, right? And they all
follow very similar steps. First, you just need
to tell it any sort of region information,
access keys are needed,
any credentials,
whatever. Right? AWS is there.
We can see GCP is similar. We just
need to access can tokens.
If you wanna run OpenStack,
know, by all means go for it. There
is metal cubed, there's packet which is now
Equinix metal, the provider hasn't been renamed yet
which just requires API key. So whatever provider
you're using,
expose the information through environment variables that you
need, run Cluster control and tell it which
infrastructure provider you require.
Here's packet,
there's GCP
and of course we have AWS.
Now that's just gonna do a few things
to our management cluster. First of all, we
need cert manager installed.
Cert manager is going to provision all of
the tokens that need for the webhook components
to work within the controllers
and then
it's going to install all of the controller
loops that we need
to the management cluster.
It also registers the CRDs are required so
that we can apply our own cluster definitions
to it. Right? Again, if you're working with
Kubernetes for any length of time, this should
feel mostly familiar.
Okay. Now that takes a few moments.
Once that becomes healthy, we then can start
to say, right, how do I create my
first workload cluster?
Well, there is a command that allows us
to generate
some of the YAML required or all of
the YAML that is required
and again cluster control is just wanting us
to expose any environment information that we need
to define how that cluster should look and
then it will generate the YAML for us.
So for AWS, we just need to tell
the region we want to create the cluster,
SSH key to make available on the nodes,
the control plane machine type and the workload
cluster machine type.
Azure is the same, GCP is the same,
Equinix metal and packet is the same. Right?
All we need to know is where to
create the cluster and the types of machines
to use.
We can also provide how many worker nodes,
how many control plane nodes we want how
many worker nodes we want. So once we've
exposed those environment variables, we can come back
to our cluster control command where we say
configure me a cluster.
We provide the name of the cluster that
we wish to create, the Kubernetes version that
we wish to deploy and then the counts
of how many machines we want on our
control plane and on
worker plane.
Now of course for the control plane, you're
gonna want to pick either one or three
depending on your use case. One being we
don't want a highly available control plane and
three being we do want a highly available
control plane. That is up to you, your
use case and what you're trying to do.
We then scale up how many worker machines
we want. It's important to note that you're
only ever gonna really get one node pool
in this configuration. However, you can modify the
YAML yourself
be able to change those machine types. Maybe
you want a,
maybe you want a node pool that has
a really high end infrastructure plus you want
a larger one that is maybe smaller or
small spot instances or something like that, right?
You know, you know what you're looking for.
However, the cluster control command line is really
basic.
So use that to get enough YAML that
you can understand how it's composed together to
be able to modify that yourself.
And then all we need to do is
kubectl apply the YAML that it spits out,
send it to our management cluster and the
controller loops will then begin to do everything
it needs to do to create
and provision our new cluster.
Now that can take anywhere from ten or
fifteen minutes to thirty minutes. It depends on
provider, depends how big the machines are, it
depends on whether you went for a single
control plane node or a highly available control
plane node. Obviously this is all gonna take
a slightly different amount of time.
Provisioning and creating Kubernetes clusters is not instantaneous.
Now there's one more thing that is really
important to note that when we do this
step is that we will not have a
working Kubernetes
cluster yet
and the reason for that is, is that
we don't have any networking within
cluster. We need to deploy our own CNI
provider that tells that how the nodes can
communicate with each other. In fact, the nodes
won't come under, their nodes won't be labeled
as ready until we have performed that step.
Now the
book here
will suggest that you install Calico and the
instructions for that are just here. You can
use whatever CNI you want, you just have
to make sure that the subnet configuration you
provide for your cluster will match. That will
be exposed to the YAML file that is
generated for you through KubeControl
config cluster.
In order to be able to do that
applying, you do need to get a KubeConfig
from the management cluster to your local machine
and there is a command for doing that
as well.
This is the very manual one that actually
pulls out the value from the secret. If
you're running a recent
version of cluster CTL, you can just run
cluster CTL get KubeConfig.
Once you've done that and deployed the CNI,
you have a production ready Kubernetes cluster ready
to do whatever you wish.
Okay.
Let's go back to the slides. So that
is how we get started with the Cluster
API using cluster control,
using all the defaults and the provider just
from the quick start.
Now what's the problem?
Well,
unfortunately there's a lot of Yamal involved, right?
And that may be no surprise to you
if you're already, you know, working with Kubernetes
but Yamal is what is what everything expects
us to write, configure,
manage,
to interact with our Kubernetes control plane and
of course there are many many memes online
about how much we are YAML engineers now
or how the only thing that the only
programming language you use to know is and
so forth and that
may get you so far but there are
limitations to how far we can go with
that YAML. So much so that we have
all of this other tooling coming out that
tries to abstract and simplify the process of
wrangling this YAML together.
One you're probably more familiar with will be
Helm, right? We use Helm to provide prepackaged
or template to build YAML configurations for applications
that we don't necessarily
understand or got completely ourselves that allow other
people who have that knowledge to produce it.
There's also tools like Capitan
or Customize
or all of those other tools, the Carvel
tools, etcetera that also provide their own abstractions
in order to handle this YAML mess that
we've gotten ourselves into.
So
I took a little bit of time and
reached out to Jason to to is one
of the, you know, maintainers and contributors to
the Cluster API project.
And I asked him what his thoughts were
on the responsibilities of the Cluster API in
regard to how the end users should consume
it.
I would read this out, you know, take
a moment to pause it if you want
to read it verbatim, but I think the
message is clear.
And Jason's opinion is that the cluster API's
primary responsibility
is the reconciliation creation and provisioning and management
of the Kubernetes clusters itself.
The responsibility is not to generate or provide
the tooling to describe those clusters, right? The
cluster API provides the CRDs, provides the spec
for how we describe
those clusters.
But really it's our responsibility to provide the
YAML.
Now, of course we already seen through the
quick start that Cluster CTL provides a really
simple method of generating some YAML from environment
variables.
And that's great for getting started, but we
need more tooling and we need other tools
to come along and help with the creation
of that YAML.
So
what would be a potential solution?
I'm a big fan of infrastructure as code
and I do not mean infrastructure as YAML.
I mean, code.
So what I want from a solution in
this space is something that is first and
foremost flexible.
Something that allows me to describe a cluster
and my configuration
with however many node pools I want with
whichever operating system or images I want, the
size and infrastructure,
you know the size of the clusters and
the node pools and the size of the
machines that I wanna use that I want.
I also wanted to be composable.
I'm probably going to be creating many many
clusters and the reason I want it to
be composable is I maybe want to have
definitions
that I can reuse across those clusters. Like
if I'm deploying some of the node groups
for stateful workloads, for storage, for memory consumption,
for databases,
for a compute machine learning with GPU's.
I wanna be able to generalize
those configurations and reuse them across my multiple
clusters
And it has to be ergonomic, has to
feel and be fun to work with to
a certain degree, right? We don't need to
take all the fun out of this stuff.
So can I have a solution that is
flexible, composable and ergonomic?
And I hope so. And I think that
the foundation
for the tooling that I'm going to show
you all comes from a project called Pulumi.
Pulumi is an infrastructure as code tool that
doesn't use DSL.
It allows you the user to use whatever
language you're comfortable with provided as supported,
but they have really good support.
And here's an example I grabbed from one
of their example repositories where they're using the
Azure provider in Pulumi
to deploy a new
function, HTTP function that it was I guess
like Lambda with an endpoint.
And you can see how simple this is
using TypeScript.
First I just create a new resource group
and give it a name. I can define
a handler which is just an anonymous function
with whatever code that I want in there
to do whatever I want it to do
and then I just say I want a
new HTTP event subscription
pointed to the resource group, pointed to the
handler
and that's it. Doing this is cool as
allows us to leverage all of the
functional or object oriented practices that we've developed
over the years for making our code reusable
and composable and of course flexible.
Now another project that is
really, really important and the libraries that I'm
going to share is something called CRD to
Pulumi.
This is a go application
by the Pulumi team. I believe it was
written by one of the interns
that allows me to pass in a Kubernetes
custom resource definition YAML file,
generate
types
for that that can be consumed
by Pulumi
projects or Pulumi end projects.
It supports all of the supported languages
that Pulumi supports.
Here I've got an example that generates
node JS which is TypeScript types
that can be reused on my project
and we'll come back to that in a
little bit too.
Now I said that the libraries, the language
support is very good for Pulumi. These are
the primary languages. I believe adding new languages
is not trivial but also not an enormous
task.
Maybe I could hack us on project one
day to try and address but
TypeScript is my preferred approach here and because
of the type system and the ergonomics of
working with the language are really good. The
tooling is good across IDEs. TypeScript
is the one that I'll be using today.
You can use go as well. You can
use Python and you can use any of
the dot net languages. I think C sharp
and F sharp seem to be quite widely
supported.
And
this is one of these things that I'm
just gonna have to spend a little bit
of hyperbole
and be like, it doesn't exist yet, but
it's coming, but I do, you know, speak
with the Pulumi team regularly and one of
the things that
I've been trying to talk to them about
and understand is
if I write composable units of Pulumi codes
that can be consumed by others is like
is there some sort of AST that I
can consume this and other
teams can consume this
even if they're not using the same language
as me.
And the answer is it's coming soon. So
while the types that I'm generating for this
Cluster API project are all in TypeScript
and the coming future short temperature I believe
is that you as a team using Pulumi
and goor.net
or Python will still be able to reuse
these composable modules,
which is really really exciting. It doesn't matter
what language I'm using, you can use the
language of your choice and still take advantage
of this without having to generate your own
types for go, for Python, for dot net
etcetera.
Very very cool.
Alright.
That's enough waffle.
The next part of this talk I'm just
going to show you
how flexible the solution is, how composable the
solution is and how ergonomic it is to
work with.
Okay, so in my demo talk directory here
I have a base Pulumi project just initiated
with Pulumi new. I've selected the Kubernetes TypeScript
and starting point which just means that I
get a TypeScript file with some example code
which I've deleted and a package dot JSON
which I've added our packages that we're using
today. I've added the Cluster API package helpers
which is this first one. The type definitions
so I can show you how those work
and then two helpers for DigitalOcean and for
Packet Cloud.
Now when I come into the index. Ts,
the first thing I wanna do is enable
a Kubernetes provider.
Now if we don't provide one it will
use whatever is available on the system. However,
I prefer to be a little bit more
explicit about it and I'll show you why
in the second part of this demo.
To get a new provider, I can do
a case provider. We give it a name
so I'll just call it Kubernetes
and then it takes a small bit of
configuration and there's some options here which I'm
not going to bother with.
Now that we have a provider, we can
install cluster API.
So let's import
star as copy
from our helper.
Like so.
And that now means
that if I type copy dot, I have
a few helper functions available. First one initialize,
second one create cluster and then something called
a feature gate that we don't know what
that is yet.
I'm gonna hit in it and then I
can see from the type system helping you
here is that we need a cluster API
config.
I can open up an object and I
get auto complete. I can say yes, let's
install cert manager because we need it and
I don't have it previously provisioned to my
management cluster.
I can specify the version
and then I oh, I have the feature
gates, which we know by hovering over this
is a list of feature gates. We can
open up a list, we can do copy
feature gate and see what is available.
I'm gonna enable cluster resources.
Finally, we have the Kubernetes provider, which we're
just gonna use the one we generated up
above.
Now I can install providers to my cluster.
So we
also know that this emit function returns manifest.
So let's make sure we store them for
later.
Okay.
Now we have our provider
deal manifests
which is gonna be for digital ocean.
So let's import that.
Well import star as
digital ocean from
Rawkode
digital ocean.
And now we can do digitalocean.edit.
And we can see here this takes a
provider config.
If we pop that open when we use
our all complete we see oh, we need
an access token.
We need a cluster API,
which is just gonna be our manifest return
from the in it and we specifically
want the cluster API ones. That's just forms
a dependency so we don't get any waste
conditions when we apply it to the cluster.
And then we can provide our Kubernetes
provider.
Now I'm not gonna use the data ocean
provider. So I will use ABC one, three
for our access token.
Next, I'm gonna import the packet provider.
Oops. Random equals.
Auto complete. We have a packet provider here
and then I can do the same. We
can say, hey, we also want
packet manifests
where we use packet in it, which also
takes a provider config,
which needs an API key.
Also one, three.
It also needs the Kubernetes provider
and also needs the cluster API.
We save it and we're done.
Okay, let's spin this up. We can run
Pulumi up.
We provide the password for our stack. It's
gonna go away and speak to the Kubernetes
cluster, work out what has to be created
and then give us a plan.
We can then decide to apply that plan
to the cluster.
Just a moment.
We had yes.
And now that's going to deploy a 30
resources to our cluster. That's provisioning cluster API,
the touch of lotion provider and
the packet provider.
Okay. Let's take a look at a more
feature complete example. So inside providers, we have
this packet example directory and there's also a
digital ocean example too.
If we open this up, we can actually
see that we're not just provisioning the Cluster
API controllers, but we have all this commented
out code
and don't worry that project ID and API
key are no longer valid but
we can first and foremost import a few
extra helpers. We have facility enumerated
that means that all the facilities that are
available can be you know, type or part
of the type system. We also have the
same for the operating systems.
Instead of having Pulumi speak directly to our
cluster, we're gonna have it render YAML to
a local director that we can apply ourselves.
Really cool way for Pulumi to work with
Kubernetes
without
building it into your CI system.
Next we skip over all the CAPI and
packet in it but we can provide a
cluster name and a project ID and then
we have a helper for creating a new
control plane. You know, we have access still
to our type system,
very very easy to work with. We have
our enumerated types for the facility,
we have operating systems which allow us to
select the container runtime that we want. If
I don't want to run container
well I can swap it out for another
supported one by the abstractions in this library.
I can see okay, we actually want Docker
installed on this machine. We provide the machine
type.
Once we have this
here, which provides the packet integration
cluster and control plane. We can enter a
copy to create a cluster and there may
be a helper to encapsulate this but for
now it's a two step process.
So here we say copy create cluster, we
provide the name of the cluster, the Kubernetes
version,
We can tell it which
pod and service side are to use and
then we pass in our cluster and our
control plane that we got previously.
And because we're using the render to YAML
as part of the provider
from the CLI,
I can come into my example repository.
Run Pulumi up.
Let's just call this a new stack.
And this will just take a second, but
it's gonna fill a directory called rendered YAML
with the YAML that I need to apply
to my cluster.
And there is. We pop open Rider Jamo,
the manifests. We can see we have a
cluster API cluster definition with our configuration that
points to a packet cluster and a packet
control
plane.
And then we can scroll down this list
a little bit more.
Let's see. We have our machine templates. We
can see that we're running a bunch of
twenty ten. We have our machine type
and
we have our packet clusters. So you can
see this is a really easy way to
work with the Cluster API
as code. Hopefully it providing the promise of
flexibility, composability and good ergonomics.
Okay. So
what are the next steps for
this project?
So more providers are coming soon. And by
the time this talk is available to you,
there will be types for AWS Azure and
Google and a few others available within the
repository. So you can begin to use this
library to deploy cluster APIs across all of
those providers using code.
However, I wanna be able to
provide the same level of abstractions across all
the other providers and I will be reaching
out to people and friends that I have
across those other providers to see what we
can do and collaborate together.
I wanna see more abstractions on top of
this, you know, this API is still very
much being defined through my own personal usage
and I would like to encourage other people
to give it a go and see how
clean we can get this and how simple
we can make Cluster API for the end
user.
I also want to see more support for
more images across providers and more operating systems,
more container run times, more CNI implementations
and all that driven through resources as well.
Lots of lots of room for people to
come and contribute and help out with this
project as well.
Thank you very much for joining me today.
I hope this library will help commoditize
cluster API for the end user across all
of the cloud providers.
You can find a code at github.com/rawcode/preliminary-kubernetes-cluster-API.
That's pretty soon.